with almost 500 sessions at next 2018
it's understandable that you couldn't
get to them all so if you didn't see CIC
D in a surveillance world then stay
tuned because here's the rewind the
development ecosystem is always changing
for companies as they look to grow and
scale their businesses continuous
integration and continuous delivery or
CIC D has become an essential process
for helping teams deliver code changes
more frequently and reliably thanks to
increases in serverless technology teams
can build and deploy their code with
even more speed and structure first
let's define what we mean by serverless
the core idea here is that we're able to
focus on running our application code
without having to worry about the
infrastructure or the underlying logic
used to run or scale our application
service options are increasing in
popularity and tools around these are
still evolving and growing rapidly in
fact Google has had a number of service
offerings going as far back as app
engine which released ten years ago all
of these cover a wide variety of
services but for CIC D will mainly be
focusing on compute offerings such as
App Engine or cloud functions so when
looking at CI CD there's a whole bunch
of things like build agents and
configuration management that we would
need to deal with in a legacy
environment instead of jumping through
hoops and managing the infrastructure
for all of these let's focus on
embracing serverless concepts and best
practices by doing this we can reduce
our overhead and spend more time on our
application service lets us focus on
making our deployments automatic faster
and safer by really drilling into the
automated tasks and process our code can
quickly go from commit to deployed and
we're able to customize build steps such
as testing and manual approval to
capture all the benefits of coding in a
surveillance world we can configure
tasks and deployment strategies as
needed such as blue green and canary for
all the processes we've just outlined we
need a tool to manage all the travelling
that our code needs to do and that's
where cloud build comes in this is a
pretty typical workflow and cloud build
hubs improve developer velocity and
manage the build steps like packaging
and testing deploying to staging and
reviewing it before finally promoting it
into production who cloud build is also
service and highly configurable with
built-in support for CLI tools
encryption for api secrets
and local build support whether building
on VMs or serverless a well-structured
CI CD pipeline lets us benefit from
automation cloud build helps us it
create the rules of the system and get
all the efficiencies without having to
worry about any of the details of the
infrastructure in the talk
Christopher Sanson takes us through a
demonstration of his new prepster shop
built on App Engine firebase and cloud
functions I definitely recommend
checking it out to see all the features
of cloud built in action and how it
really enables CI CD in a serverless
world if you'd like to see the full talk
check out the link in the description
below and don't forget to subscribe to
the cloud YouTube channel for more great
next rewind content thanks for watching
you
[Music]